LORIN PRICE: My
name is Lorin Price.
I'm a Networking Specialist
Customer Engineer
at Google Cloud.
And today I'm going to talk
to you about the networking
concepts for Cloud
Data Fusion that
are helpful to know for
implementation, security,
and connectivity.
[INTRO MUSIC]
Cloud Data Fusion is
Google Cloud's native
managed service for enterprise
data integration and ingestion.
It provides a visual
point-and-click interface
enabling a code free deployment
of ETL and ELT data pipelines.
Cloud Data Fusion has a number
of components that exist behind
the scenes that
power the service,
and it creates a
tenant project and VPC
to hold those resources.
The Data Fusion components
that are surfaced to the user
are the Data Fusion instance
and the Dataproc clusters.
Each Cloud Data Fusion instance
contains a unique independent
Cloud Data Fusion
deployment that
contains a set of services
that handle pipeline lifecycle
management, orchestration,
coordination,
and metadata management.
Cloud Data Fusion creates
ephemeral execution
environments to run
pipelines when you manually
run your pipelines
or when pipelines
run through a time schedule
or a pipeline state trigger.
Cloud Data Fusion uses Dataproc
as an execution environment
in which you can choose to run
pipelines as Spark or Spark
streaming programs.
Cloud Data Fusion provisions
an ephemeral Dataproc cluster
in the user project at the
beginning of a pipeline
run, executes the pipeline
using Map Reduce or Spark
in the cluster, and then deletes
the cluster after the pipeline
execution is complete.
Alternatively, if you manage
your Dataproc clusters
in controlled
environments, you can also
configure Cloud Data Fusion not
to provision ephemeral clusters
and run pipelines against
existing data clusters instead.
The Cloud Data
Fusion instance can
be thought of as the
design environment
and the Dataproc cluster as
the execution environment.
There are two types of
Cloud Data Fusion instances
based on an access
model, a public instance,
which is the default deployment,
and a private instance.
Let's dig into the
access patterns
from different scenarios.
We can start with the public
IP deployment pattern.
In a public instance,
network communication
happens over the open
internet regardless
of the source location,
which is not recommended
for critical environments.
The Cloud Data Fusion instance
for the design environment
will have a public IP.
However, the data cluster used
for the execution environment
can be deployed with either
public IP or private IPs.
Let's move on to the private
IP deployment pattern.
Cloud Data Fusion private
IP has different setup steps
depending on whether you
are using a standard VPC
or a shared RPC network.
If you're using a
standard VPC, you
can create the instance
using either the Cloud
Console or a cURL command.
However, if you are
using a shared VPC,
you must use a cURL command.
Check out the
documentation that's
linked in the description
for more information.
When private IP
instances are created,
a separate tenant
project is created
for each user project in
which Cloud Data Fusion
instances are provisioned.
Additionally, Cloud
Data Fusion private IP
requires peering in connection
to communicate privately
with sources located
in the user VPC
and is required for the design
environment capabilities.
This peering connection
must be created manually.
If you need to access a public
source using a private IP Cloud
Data Fusion instance
when designing pipelines,
you must use version
6.4 or above.
In the design environment,
Cloud Data Fusion traffic
will traverse a VPC peer from
the tenon VPC to the user VPC.
Traffic will then be
directed to an internal load
balancer fronting a managed
instance group of gateway VMs.
Traffic will egress
through the gateway VMs
through a Cloud NAT
configured for the subnet
into the public source
on the internet.
The Dataproc cluster used
for the execution environment
should be configured to
egress through the Cloud NAT
as well to reach
the public source.
For sources that are
hosted within the user VPC,
Cloud Data Fusion will
connect over a VPC peer.
Firewalls must be
configured in the source VPC
to allow the source to
communicate with the Cloud Data
Fusion instance, as well as the
Dataproc execution environment.
If you are in a peered hub
and spoke architecture model
and you are trying to make
a connection from a VPC that
is not directly peered to the
Cloud Data Fusion tenant VPC,
you must use a proxy
due to the nontransitive
routing nature of Google's VPCs.
This will only be needed
for the design environment.
Be aware you can also
replace a peering hub
and spoke architecture
with a VPN hub
and spoke model so that the
Cloud Data Fusion 10 and BPC
route can be advertised
over the VPN.
Nontransitive peering
also comes into play
when trying to connect to
a Google Cloud source that
is deployed using
another tenant project,
for example, Cloud SQL, Cloud
Data Fusion and Cloud SQL
are both hosted in
tenant projects,
but these projects
are different.
In order for Cloud Data Fusion
to connect to a Cloud SQL
source, a proxy VM
must be deployed
in the user VPC to proxy traffic
to the Cloud SQL instance
when using the
design environment.
Since the Dataproc clusters used
in the execution environment
are hosted in the
user VPC, they will
be able to connect to Cloud SQL
without the use of the proxy.
When accessing sources in an
on prem environment with Cloud
Data Fusion private
IP, a hybrid connection
must exist between the user
VPC and on prem environment,
either a HA VPN or
interconnect can be used.
Both the IP side arrange
for the tenant VPC
where the Cloud Data Fusion
instance is hosted as well
as the IP side range
of the Dataproc cluster
in the user VPC
must be advertised
over the hybrid connection.
And on prem firewalls must be
configured to accept ingress
from these ranges.
If the VLAN or VPN lands
in another peered VPC, then
you'll need to use a proxy to
connect the source to the Cloud
Data Fusion instance.
When accessing data sources,
both public and private
instances make outgoing
calls to Google Cloud APIs
using private Google access.
Let's briefly cover
some security topics.
For Cloud Data Fusion
versions below 6.5,
you can only manage access
at an instance level.
If you have access
to an instance,
you have access to all pipelines
and metadata in that instance.
For version 6.5
and above, you also
have the ability to use
role-based access control
to establish name space level
isolation within a single Cloud
Data Fusion instance.
This feature is
currently in preview.
Pipeline access to data is
provided by granting access
to the service account,
which can be a custom service
account that you specify.
You must make sure that the
service account has proper IAM
permissions in place to access
any Google Cloud hosted data
sources.
For a pipeline execution, you
control ingress and egress
by setting the
appropriate firewall
rules on the user VPC on which
the pipeline is being executed.
Before we wrap up, let's
summarize the three most
important takeaways from today.
Cloud Data Fusion exists
as a design environment
that runs within a
tenant project in VPC
and an execution environment
that runs as a data cluster
within the user VPC.
Cloud Data Fusion
can be launched
with a public IP or private IP,
and VPC peering must manually
be configured between
the tenant VPC and user
VPC for private IP.
Firewall rules must be
configured to allow connections
to and from both the Cloud
Data Fusion instant [? sider ?]
and the Dataproc [? sider. ?]
Thanks for watching,
and look out for another video
on the concepts of networking
for Google Cloud's
managed services.
[MUSIC PLAYING]